[Music]
[Applause]
well
why don't you why don't you try to look
that up while i bring in jalen hurts the
uh eagles quarterback joining us on the
program now you were at alabama you
started your career there then you
transferred to oklahoma
if if both of those teams are playing
uh game on saturday
which game are you watching
flipping back and forth
you know lucky this week um
alabama i think oklahoma played before
alabama played so
i was able to watch oklahoma and then
abc
alabama came on next so i got the best
of both worlds what if alabama played
oklahoma and both head coaches called
you
and wanted to have your thoughts on it
who would you call back first
probably i can't put them on three-way i
can't do that
[Laughter]
but i definitely i i definitely i
definitely talk to them both and i'm the
beautiful thing about both of those
schools is i have so much love for both
of them my mom i've made great memories
at both universities um have a lot of
respect for both coaches and what they
do and what they stand for so
um
i guess i got the best of both worlds
now
do you know about uh we had josh jacobs
on
and uh and i said i you got to tell me a
story about saban
and he said saban's funny in practice he
said but um
he likes to use the expression deez nuts
did coach saban ever use the expression
deez nuts do you
oh man yeah coach saban
coach sabre has his way of doing things
um
he's definitely a character he's
definitely funny is that a yes jalen
hey he he may use that he may use
something else um
he has jokes though so
it's funny it's funny that you you bring
that up because
i don't know that
it's just funny
and true
that's a run that's a random funny thing
i feel like
what was it like though when you decided
to leave what was that feeling like
you know when i left alabama um i wanted
to leave um the right way you know and i
i wanted to get my degree i wanted to
graduate i felt that was very important
for me um and i got that and
honestly coach saban
we talked and he wasn't the reason why i
made the decision i made
but
the fact that he was honest
and
and gave me a helping hand
uh with the process and stuff like that
um he wanted he wanted to see me succeed
and shine
and um he wanted me to he encouraged me
to go to the to the school with the best
players
um
you know that was oklahoma and
considering what they had done with
quarterbacks before me baker and kyler
um
it all worked out the way it was
supposed to
what did those two say to you when you
reached out to baker and kyler
they they they just told me you know
trust coach um trust this process we
have here oklahoma and come in and be
yourself you know they they told me you
know you won a lot of games you you've
had a lot of success already
i mean you have championships
so just be yourself and everything go or
fall into place
when's the last time you felt totally
secure
in your job as a quarterback
i'm always i always feel secure
every every day
rent is due i've always said that you
have to you know
take those steps every day
but
that's a that's a self-imposed thing
well
what was your reaction when the eagles
traded for gardner minshew
a great addition to the room um
i mean that's the decision they made and
we talked about it so
it was a great addition to the room but
you don't listen you don't feel
threatened by it
it's another player i can lean on
um with joe
and learn from i know gardner has some
experience playing as joe does and um
it's all helpful for me have you
exchanged jerseys with anybody in the
nfl
the nfl yeah um
i have with a few of my old teammates a
few friends
what about rivals or
the opposing quarterbacks you've done
that yeah
not just yet not just yet you know last
year they made a big deal about it with
the
um
with the colby virus and everything so
they had limitations on it
uh tell us what you're doing with uh the
fedex air and ground nfl awards this
year
yes i've been working with them um
they're actually launching the campaign
to encourage fans to vote weekly for ed
fedex air and ground player of the week
and fedex has been doing this for the
past 19 years it's a great thing
um i say that because they're they're
donating about four thousand dollars
every week to hbcus across the country
um to
you know let them fulfill their needs
from as a school
um
it's just a great it's just a great
thing i'm happy to be a part of it
uh you got your communications degree or
is that did you minor in communications
at alabama
minored in communications uh major in
public relations all right so what do
you want to do when you grow up
i want to play football but i think if i
go back um well it won't last forever
obviously
but i thought about maybe coaching or
being in the operations role
or whatever it is
somewhere i can lead
impact the people around me
could you see yourself playing when
you're 45 like tom brady
i mean i don't know i i i i don't know
what i'm eating tomorrow
tonight
brady is
is 20 years 21 years older than you
yeah that sounds about right that's
crazy
yeah
it is crazy
he's had a great career
uh hey good luck this season and uh
great to talk to you thanks again for
joining us
thank you sir nice to meet you that's
jalen hurts